now one of the things that's challenging
about the intervals that you guys means
extension to students is that sometimes
they look like you can't integrate them
because they are two or more integrals
masquerading as one okay so here's an
example right now this doesn't look like
it fits any of our nice sleep patterns
right this certainly not the derivative
of this no even saw a close but it's not
there so what am I going to do is right
so I'm going to take the suggestion all
seeing that I can split apart numerators
but you can't just split apart
denominators without doing partial
fractions which will look out tomorrow
but liberators easy to deal with so if I
break this into half like so it becomes
a little clearer there at least that
right hand part of the integrand right
what is that that's a standard phone
that's sine inverse of X odd to write
because it's um 2 squared minus x
squared so that's easy to deal with the
left hand side not that neat but it's
still like I can cope with it if i
rewrite it because rephrasing the
question as you know sometimes make it's
so much more obvious if i rewrite it
like this you can see and you see what's
going to hear this is a pretty standard
case of reverse here because the
derivative of the inside function is
negative 2x which is only off by a
constant from what's on the outside so
that's basically going to be my F dash
yeah so sometimes you'll see something
you know it's kind of like that of that
feature of like two children so standing
on like once they do and shoulder the
trench coat around what is this thing
walking around it's like it's not one
thing it's two things and then they're
very easy to deal with so here are two
examples and they end up with logs once
you work with them watch this guy here
looks like one right looks like a single
integral but if I play a little bit of
algebra here I can go through and I can
actually carry out a division and
separate things out if i take my one and
add one we saw this trick it's some that
early
questions right then what you got is a
part of the numerator that I can simply
remove and it cancels right you've got
this guy here which is just going to
become one and then you've got this guy
which becomes this is a log of AB
because we're in extension to it's the
right time to say the absolute value of
X minus one and there's my console now
that's fine and you should absolutely do
it that sort of quick way if you can see
it however I don't know about you but I
always met a bit of settling when people
said to me all you subtract 1 i'll
explain that a bit arbitrary and it
doesn't always work it's not very
systematic right so sure you look at
something like this when you do with
that right in this case right I've got a
variety of choices but being that the
degree of the numerator is bigger than
the degree of the denominator it seems
most straightforward to me actually
feedback to last term what I did with
polynomials and just divide it I can't
factorize it straight because the
factorization won't yield something
which is X minus 1 but i can divide
through by x minus 1 if i want just for
the sake of it because it's been a while
I'll do it long instead of synthetic so
if I have X minus if i have x squared
plus 2x plus 3 help me out up top x
which means x squared take away x 0 3 X
plus 3 up top + 33 x minus three which
needs to be weird six that's my
remainder so what does the division
transformation tell me that I can do
with the newberry i can rewrite it as X
minus 1 times X plus 3 I mean what's
left over right plus 6 so I'm going to
do that x minus 1 x plus 3 plus 6 and
now I'm in the same boat that I was at
this line
right so you've got that part which is
easy to remove X plus 3 yeah plus this
part which is still a fraction so I
haven't agreed yet and then you just
proceed just like you did before expert
on to plus 3x plus what six log of
absolute value X minus one and there's a
constant okay so sometimes you'll see
this right and you've got to sometimes
push on and see well if I can't deal
with it with my standard forms now do I
have to break it apart in subway take
advantage of what i learned from pollen
over yours in order to do that okay and
partial fractions like i said we're
going to look at them too